à vendre l'émission ont discuté avec
patrick mennucci sur des cas par exemple
en ariège il suffit souvent qu'il ya un
imam
il comprit converti un qui a une
certaine influence pour qu'il arrive à
agréger autour de lui donc c'est la
présence d'un imam qui fait que à force
à jouy c'est un ensemble voyez alors là
on a vu un reportage c'est bien naturel
et je parle sous le contrôle de
dominique de montvalon qui a dirigé une
grande rédaction au parisien les
habitants n'aiment pas être stigmatisés
par la presse et par le national donc il
ya une réaction patriotique normal mais
néanmoins des critiques de ceux qui
suivent un peu de ces questions là c'est
considérer plutôt que l'état est en
retard
on a fermé la rapport à la menace plutôt
que l'averse prenons des éléments
purement objective puisque les
municipales arrive un jeu passe votre
contrôle mais dans une cinquantaine de
bureaux de vote les listes
communautariste font plus de 10% au dos
qu'il ya des facteurs une réelle
différence qui joue très peu très peu de
paris a sûrement bien sûr
[Musique]